bonsoir vous avez entendu je suis un
artiste et en fait tu peux être un
aussi j'ai pris ça au passage je
n'ai pas preuve est préparée du tout je
suis un artiste donc quelqu'un de
particulier les artistes en particulier
par exemple je ne suis pas quand on dit
ah vous êtes artiste c'est très gentil
c'est très aimable sa part est charmant
et moi je suis très charmant du tout je
suis pas aimable du tout je suis un peu
le tour noir de cette soirée qui est
destiné à l'empathie j'ai pas prendre je
sais pas travailler je suis un cancre et
comme je ne suis pas aimable vous vous
aurez le prétend le droit de ne pas
m'aimer
je suis même parfois détestable
vous aurez le droit de me détester ce
que je vais essayer de vous apporter
c'est une compréhension de pourquoi là
plupart des vrais artistes sont des
vendus salopards ce sont des foutus
salopards parce que fondamentalement ils
ont un rôle
ils ont une mission ravis et cette
mission c'est d'apporter quelque chose
de vraiment apporter quelque chose au
genre humain
quand je vous parlais d'empathie je veux
pas dire d'empathie en particulier
envers tel ou tel individu ça ça n'a
pratiquement pas de place chez les ch et
les artistes ceux qui peuvent avoir ces
une empathie pour le genre humain
c'est à dire ils doivent apporter
quelque chose qui leur permettra dans
l'idéal de s'élever d'aller plus haut
que ce que le quotidien peut leur
montrer
c'est à dire de partir dans l'imaginaire
et d'en tirer quelque chose en tirer un
un produit alors pour ce faire je je
vais vous proposer un voyage un voyage
qui qui est un voyage dans le temps
je vais vous donner au cours de cette
discussion
trois étapes majeures en quatre ça
dépendra de comment je sens les choses
qui sont des étapes majeures dans
l'histoire de l'art alors je vous ai dit
que j'étais un cancre c'est vrai je suis
quelqu'un qui n'y connaît pas grand
chose mais qui adore la ce et c'est ma
passion et je ne vis que pour ça et je
dois dire que quand je dis que les
artistes sont devenus salopards c'est
que en fait ce qui compte pour eux c'est
de faire c'est de créer plaire ou ne pas
plaire ça c'est réservé à ceux qui sont
pas de vrais artistes
vrai artiste ils sont complètement de
plaire ce qu'il veut c'est créer quelque
chose qui existe et qui reste c'est pour
ça que le premier voyage que nous allons
faire interner h dans le temps nous
allons remonter à la préhistoire
et voici une
une image qui est la première
manifestation de l'art par des humains
bien sûr puisque avec des humains qui
font de l'art ce sont des mains que les
hommes et les femmes
puisqu'on sait aujourd'hui qu'ils
avaient beaucoup de femmes qu'il
pratiquait sa part des mesures
scientifiques qui ont imposé leurs mains
sur les parois d'une grotte et ce
faisant
après avoir vaporisé des pigments autour
de leurs mains les mains restait comme
des traces dans le temps des traces qui
sont quittes dont ils ont eu en tout les
cas l'impression qu'elle serait là pour
toujours et c'est ça qui est important
c'est que le premier geste qui
existaient bien avant l'écriture
la première façon d'exister pour les
humains
c'était de dire regardez j'existe il ya
quelque chose qui écrit là pour plus
tard regardez c'est au cas où
j'oublierai un an tout à l'heure c'est
regarder j'existe et ma façon de montrer
c'est de marquer ma main pour toujours
sur les parois d'une caverne est
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est que ça plutôt
bien durer puisque c'est ces témoignages
de leurs existences qui était témoignage
d'une envie de perdurer dans le temps de
ne pas disparaître avec leur mort ce qui
est d'ailleurs une envie de beaucoup
d'artistes en particulier de ceux qui
font de ce qu'on appelle du street art
qui qui est bête leurs tags partout et
qui en fait ne font pas plus que ce que
faisaient les hommes préhistoriques
c'est à dire qu'ils sont bien en retard
sur ce que l'art peut être et l'art doit
être qui est quelque chose d'extrêmement
sensible et intelligent en même temps
donc après cette période là nous allons
vous faire un autre bond dans le temps
un grand bond puisque nous allons passer
au xvième siècle avec une peinture qui
s'appelle les ambassadeurs
alors cette peinture est très
particulière puisque l jeu tellement peu
de chose en tête que gg j'ai
heureusement des notes alors les
ambassadeurs c'est un tableau peint par
hans holbein le jeune en 15/100 33 ce
tableau représente un jeune évêque qui
rend visite à son ami diplomate en
angleterre ce qui est important c'est
que c'est pas tellement les deux
personnages qui sont importants aussi
mais parce qu'ils nous disent beaucoup
sur les coutumes sur les époques
ce qui est important c'est que ce
tableau est déjà un tableau symbolique
parce qu'il cache un certain nombre d'
indices c'est un tableau qui est célèbre
pour sa i tous les objets qui sont
passés chaque objet qui est passé au
centre entre les deux personnages
révèlent leur intérêt commun pour les
arts les sciences l'astronomie les
voyages la découverte la musique et la
vie et la mort et la mort est présente
sous forme d'une son appel une
anamorphose c'est la partie au centre
vers le bas qui est en diagonale et qui
est en fait est un crâne une tête de
mort qui est anamorphosée c'est à dire
que pour l'avoir véritablement comme il
faut il faut avoir une loupe ou bien un
1 ou bien un objet semi réfléchissant
concave et donc tout ça tout ça c'est
pour dire et je vous répète les mots du
2 le message qui est caché par le
peintre et qui est jeu mais sachet c'est
l'intérêt pour les arts conduit à une
compréhension plus profonde dont +
véritable de la vie et de la mort
cette eau voyez encore cette même
préoccupation qui est celle de l'artiste
refaisons un petit bond dans le temps
avec une autre oeuvre qui s'appelle le
cri et c'est une oeuvre d'un artiste
dans mes chiens qui s'appelait edvard
munch
alors là au delà de on est toujours
figuratif mais un peu moins c'est à dire
que on a quelque chose qui s'approche de
l'abstraction
le personnage n'est pas hyper réaliste
ce tableau est très connue très célèbre
il est en fait devenu le tableau le plus
cher du monde puisqu'il a été vendue
pour 120 millions de dollars
et pourtant ça a l'air de pas grand
chose mais pourquoi est-ce que ça a été
un bouleversement dans l'art c'était à
bruz versement par ce que il manifeste
un état d'âme il manifeste une émotion
c'est à dire que de l'art intellectuelle
on est passé à 1 1 plus émotionnelle
dans le temps et je vais vous lire ce
que l'artiste a dit à propos de son
travail
il disait un soir je marchais suivant un
chemin
j'étais fatigué malade je me suis arrêté
pour regarder le ciel
le soleil se couchait et les nuages
étaient rouges comme du sang j'ai senti
passer un cri dans la nature et il m'a
semblé que je pouvais entendre le cri
les couleurs hurlait couleur sang voilà
c'est tout ce que je veux dire je cette
étape là on va tout de suite passer à la
suivante
euh pardon excusez moi ça c'est le les
risques de ne rien apprendre de tout
faire je vais vous raconter plus tôt ce
qui s'est passé entre temps et notre
époque c'est à dire il ya environ
70 80 ans il ya eu un grand
bouleversement dans l'art il ya un
artiste qui est arrivé qui était un
artiste exceptionnel
cet artiste a développé un très très
grand nombre de deux façons différentes
de voir et de percevoir l'art en
particulier l'art est devenu au delà la
peinture et de la sculpture c'est devenu
dollar qu'on pouvait faire avec son
corps ou tout sur son corps c'est du
body art c'est devenu de l'art vidéo de
l'art numérique plus récemment après sa
mort est entre autres c'est devenu aussi
des performances
alors je vais vous expliquer maintenant
ce que c'est qu'une performance
une performance
c'est une oeuvre d'art fugitive vivante
éphémère dans la guerre laquelle l' art
l'artiste le plus souvent rêvé revient
lui mais lui même et essayer de carats
de caractère plutôt sky spirituel
fileuse de philosophie somme symbolique
plutôt lui tôt que d'environnement
éthiques
ceci est un dessin original que j'ai
fait d'après la silhouette de picasso
que j'ai interprétés et portant la
signature authentique de picasso
je veux dire qu'une performance se passe
généralement dans une galerie d'art ou
dans une institution et qu'elle est
faite pour un plus petit groupe de
personnes que nous avons ici c'est pour
ça qu'on la meilleure vidéo pour que
vous puissiez bien d'avoir même
performance ne se termine pas comme ça
elle se termine par le fait que je
ramasse les cendres dans un bocal et que
du coup ce bocal devient une urne
puisque j'ai brûlé l'effigié de picasso
ça prendrait beaucoup de temps pour nous
expliquer pourquoi mais il ya des
raisons qui sont mental qui sont
intellectuelle et cette urne qui est là
la fin de la performance c'est que je me
tourne vers le public y est présent dans
la galerie en dix ans cette urne
contient des cendres d'un dessin
original un lien et d'une signature
authentique de picasso qui veulent
acheter
et combien tout ça c'est pour montrer
que le public prend du coup il est en
question et il va prendre conscience que
généralement il n'est pas très courageux
généralement il va acheter des
signatures en tout cas les
collectionneurs achète et signatures ils
ne courent aucun risque alors la
personne qui a permis l'évolution de
toutes ces choses tour la performance
s'appelait marcel duchamp et marcel
duchamp révolutionner c'est son portrait
révolutionné l'art contemporain et il a
révolutionné notamment grâce à une
oeuvre qui s'appelle un ready made
ready-made voulant dire c'est quelque
chose qu'on trouve trouvait par exemple
ceci pourrait être un ready made si je
le transformer en oeuvres d'art
et comment est ce qu'on le transforme en
oeuvre d'art est bien par une
provocation
cette oeuvre s'appelle vous fontaine et
c'est l'oeuvre la plus controversée de
l'histoire de l'art la plus controversée
cette oeuvre est aujourd'hui pourtant
exposé dans les trois plus grands musées
d'art du monde alors sa valeur est
considéré comme absolument inestimable
donc cette oeuvre comme vous pouvez le
voir je vais vous raconter son histoire
en 1917 marcel duchamp artiste décide
d'envoyer l'exposent à l'exposition des
artistes indépendants de new york un
urinoir en porcelaine sous le pseudonyme
de richard munz et la signature qui est
apposée sur le côté aujourd'hui il est
universellement considérée que
l'important n'est pas que marcel duchamp
et fabriqué cette sculpture avec ses
mains ou non mais qu'il ait choisi un
objet de la vie courante en proposant un
nouveau regard louvre gars et ne
serait-ce que déjà le fait de le
basculer
il n'est pas dans son sens normal il est
basculée 90° il est posé sur son dos
désormais l'art consiste en une nouvelle
pensée de l'objet en homme saha
conceptuel
alors je vous ai dit que j'étais
peut-être
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
je vais peut-être en bousculer un
certain nombre d'entre vous en disant
que finalement moi je vous invite à
aimer l'art l'adoré parce que c'est la
seule chose qui peut vous élever un peu
plus haut que la vie courante que nous
voyons l'exemple que je vais vous donner
c'est une rencontre entre c'est le nom
que j'ai marqué là et qu'évidemment je
me souviens mais il est très dur à
prononcer une rencontre entre
rabindranath tagore et einstein
ils se sont rencontrés en 1917 est ravi
d'être rabin dans la traque tagore est
un penseur philosophe écrivain qui a eu
le prix nobel de littérature en 1919 je
crois et qui dans sa conversation avec
einstein
il lui dit il était artiste aussi il lui
dit tu sais il faut que je dise une
chose à propos de l'art
c'est une métaphore voilà c'est la
métaphore c'est l'histoire d'une mythe
et 7 me tu manges du papier mais voilà
la mite est une mite elle ne sait pas
que le papier qu'elle mange est un livre
autrement dit elles attrapent dévorer
une oeuvre d'art mais elle ne peut pas
le savoir
donc la question que je vous pose
aujourd'hui à certains d'entre vous
puisque certains comme moi sont déjà
convaincus de la pertinence les d'aimer
l'art c'est vous voulez vous ceux qui ne
sont pas convaincus
restait une mite ou devenir humain c'est
un j'ai conscience
j'ai conscience que vous n'allez pas
mais mais comme je le dis mais c'est
important
c'est alors comment est ce qu'on peut
savoir si si c'est bien compris j'avais
oublié encore c'est de se dire
finalement est-ce que ce gobelet tel que
vous le voyez là est un gobelet ou bien
est ce que c'est une oeuvre d'art voilà
j'en remercie
mais